ho finalmente un [ __ ] blog in vacanza
non va fatto in vacanza c'è una vacanza
seria perché in realtà sono qua
veramente coi miei genitori non è come
tipo quando va da los angeles sono
proprio tranquillo questi sette giorni e
niente ragazzi sono in spagna con i miei
genitori appunto è la mia migliore amica
denise che tratto non so dove sono dove
cazzo sono andati non ne ho idea
mi piace ho detto devo volgare delle
cose non li ho più visti no perché lo si
vergognano la pria nei video mi vorrei
farvi notare la magnificenza dei
manichini che ci sono in spagna
ma li tengono fuori anche di notte
questi che a [ __ ] giovino aspetta
aspetta aspetta
mi sento nei giovani
poi è iniziata una bambina per tornare
in hotel
ho deciso di prendere questa strada che
costeggia tutto il mare bellissimo
trovata io e fuochi proprio laggiù
bellissima lei incazzata perché lo sto
facendo a camminare sulla spiaggia sai
non siamo al mare dove vuoi camminare
vabbè ma è figo guarda che figo cioè non
inficia no no no no su dante zio ma non
è ghiaia magia quelli questa abbia più o
meno che non scavalcare non ci torneremo
più a casa
noi dobbiamo scavalcare sei contenta
famiglia faccia contenta bravissima kama
kama un torneo ed io ho un addio poi ci
ammazziamo da jesi dai letti da ioan
tanto dobbiamo muoverci effetto molto a
suo agio in questa impresa perfetto
brava bravissima da voi la bella notizia
è quella era solo la prima ce ne sono
altre 200 tutti e così si è sono nel
ristorante dell'albergo so se si vede
si si tiene anche la cappa di mio padre
la cosa particolare difficile di questo
ristorante che quando finisce di
mangiare c'è dessert che ti puoi
prendere tutto l'anno il dessert e poi
hanno anche le caramelle le caramelle
non so se state capendo le caramelle il
dessert le caramelle le serre le
caramelle
non è possibile non è possibile c'è
dentro ogni albergo ce sta roba
ma io cioccio 21 anni ma vado lì dentro
questa bambina qui me ne frega un cazzo
e posso tornare piccolo per 5 minuti vi
prego iddio e dopo una vita ho trovato
colui che ha i capelli più ordinati dei
miei porca [ __ ] zio fate come lui
usate pantene ma non vuol dire niente ai
50 anni potrebbe essere così e va bene
basta
io volevo dormire stasera pensiamo in
camera e si aspetta che non si rivede e
vabbè ma [ __ ] salve siamo a lloret
de mar
la cosa che mi sa che mi è saltata
all'occhio il nome di st pizzeria
va bene e con questa capacità e finali
ragas al santa madonna in questo caso sì
la madonna
ciao ciao ha funzionato lega livello e
che ho urlato e la madonna comuniste
ragazze i miei genitori sono lampi mi
hanno sentito anche loro prove facciamo
guida niente sarebbe tipo la riccione
mettiamola così dalla spagna quindi è
pieno di ragazzi che aspettano di
entrare in discoteca anche se questo qua
è un negozio porno però vabbè qui ci
sono un sacco di cartelloni di dj che
fanno le serate qua e indovinate un po
chi cazzo c'è il pagante ma come in
spagna mostrano salute
questo dato perché fan in spagna a
classimo che stiamo sofia a da milan
ammirarvi ammirarlo lotus cigno ha
paragonato are colombo grande bonito
contiamo le oche 12345678 lo sapevi
stare girato così diverse volte si
evolve fermi
la cosa divertente di quando sei in
piscina e c'è la musica e che vedi la
gente che quando parte la canzone di
madonna ed esaltata
il grande uomo che prende la palla ci
prova siculo
noi di porca [ __ ]
lei becca ma che culo ciaio ha vinto mio
padre ma veramente
bravo bravo papà hai vinto cosa ho vinto
il compito a per ubriacarti di più belli
voleva uno stiloso sto bambino credetemi
non farlo perché perché la vita è bella
ai giardiniere ha visti i tempi il
giardiniere suicida sono lavori che col
eccolo superman gesù per me ci sono da
prendere e cosa fa ma no a cena e party
qua e il ristorante il gigantesco abbia
finito di mangiare adesso visto che oggi
è l'ultimo giorno ci hanno dato questo
che il foglietto per dare una
valutazione a ogni cosa
mettendo il pallino nella casella giusta
e io ho scritto con i pallini vota trump
poi di accoglierlo con segni tech e
niente ragazzi siamo addio l'ascella
siamo all'ultimo giorno e niente adesso
trovo per concludere il video perché mi
sono messo a montare il video in vacanza
c'è questo è il cesso l'ultimo giorno
appuntarsi con una video da porre questa
non è mia e rosa ma non è mia e di denis
anche questo non è mio
niente ragazzi torniamo praticamente
domani quindi io devo chiudere qua così
mi metto a montare il video si ce
l'avete bello pronto per domani e
concludiamo qui spero che vi lewis
partito l'ascom io dico che i ragazzi
servizio che ci sono 700 commento non mi
piace anche presto il musical che parte
a caso anche la pagina di facebook e co
il bello che si ferma anche la faccenda
si fa cazzo
cisco madonna che ricordi ok posso posso
anche la pagina di facebook e come nei
video tale descrizione di schede ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bene
ragazzi